ADAM MARTIN: So, last semester,
my grandfather passed away,
and I was responsible for
explaining to my two sons
how a funeral works.
So I'm a professor, right?
I pride myself on being able
to explain things clearly.
So I went to tell
my five-year-old son
sort of what's going
on during the funeral.
I told him, your papa's body is
up in that wooden box up there.
We're going to
celebrate him right now.
We're going to go
to the cemetery,
and then we're
going to bury him.
And you know, I'm a professor.
I thought I nailed it, OK?
Except my son was
showing this looking
look of concern in his eyes.
And he looked at me.
He was like, what
about his head?
So my plea for this
semester is please let me
know when I've forgotten
the part about the head, OK?
You know, you guys
are listening to me.
I might have forgotten
something that,
to me, seems kind of obvious,
but that, for you, it
would help to know to
understand the material.
So today, we're going
to start with cells.
And so here, you can see this
is one of my favorite movies.
This is a neutrophil cell
here that's migrating.
You can see it's chasing
after this smaller
cell which is a bacteria cell.
And around this neutrophil,
what you're seeing here
are these red blood
cells, which aren't
doing very much of anything.
So the point I'm
making with this video
is that cells have a
huge amount of diversity.
So cells have diversity.
As you can see from the video,
there's a diversity in size.
There's diversity in shape and
also diversity in behavior.
OK, so we're going to
unpack this a little bit.
And I just want to start
by just pointing out
that until now in the
semester, we've dealt mainly
with very small things, such as
atoms, small molecules, lipids,
and proteins.
And the size of these
structures, they're
on the nanometer scale.
Now, cells are a
unit up in size.
Cells span several orders
of magnitude in size.
So bacterial cells
are on the small side.
They're on the 1 micron
to 10 micron size.
So you can see that here.
Most bacteria is about
1 micron to 10 micron.
But our cells span from tens of
microns to hundreds of microns,
and even larger than that,
because the human egg
is on the order of a
millimeter in size.
This is not a human egg,
but this is a frog egg.
You can see often the egg cells
are the biggest of all cells.
The biggest cell
is an ostrich egg.
It's about 15
centimeters, I believe.
So cells span a huge,
wide range of sizes.
I'm going to start with
the simplest, which
is a bacteria cell.
And what I want to point
out about this cell
is its simplicity.
So here, you can see this
is an electron micrograph
of bacterial cell here.
And this is a cartoon
just illustrating
some of the key features.
You have a plasma
membrane and a cell wall.
The cell wall here is in sort
of-- the periplasmic space
is in green.
And this encapsulates
the cytoplasm.
And the only other real
structure you can see,
in this case, is this nucleoid
structure in the middle.
And what the
nucleoid is, is it's
just the chromosome
of the bacterium.
And I want to point out
that later on in the course,
Professor Imperiali is going
to come back and tell you
about antibiotics and
how bacteria can develop
antibiotic resistance, which
is of critical importance
for biology and medicine.
So our cells are more
complicated than this.
And that's because if
you look at this EM here,
you can see that
eukaryotic cells--
and we are eukaryotes--
have membrane-bound
compartments.
There's a nucleus here that
houses our nuclear DNA.
And also, there's a series
of membrane compartments
that span the cytoplasm.
Now, our cells, even in a single
organism, such as us, our cells
have incredible diversity
and specialization.
So there's diversity
within a single organism.
There is specialization.
So as we develop
from a single cell,
our cells acquire
properties that
allow them to carry out specific
functions in our bodies.
And an extreme example
of this is shown up here.
These are pictures or drawings
of neurons from Ramon y Cajal,
and you can see how
this looks nothing
like the cartoon picture of
a cell I just showed you.
These cells have
highly dendritic sort
of arrays of protrusions.
And these cells
have evolved such
that they are very good at sort
of transmitting information
in the body, right?
An extreme example of a
nerve is a sciatic nerve,
which extends from the
base of your spinal cord
all the way down into your foot.
So it's about a meter long.
That's an extreme
specialization for a cell.
So these cells are
specialized, but what's
important to note is that
within a single organism,
the genomic DNA of a cell
is more or less the same.
So genomic DNA is the same, with
some exceptions, some of which
we'll get to in the course.
The genomic DNA is the same.
What's different
is the genes that
are being expressed in
these cells and the proteins
that they encode that give
these cells different functions.
So what's different and
what allows cells to acquire
these different functionalities
is this different gene
expression.
OK, so that's the overview.
Now I want to talk
about compartments.
And if we go back
to this cartoon
that I showed you from your--
oh, I just wanted to
point out that right now,
at MIT and the Broad,
there is a project
that's ongoing to really
define all the cell types that
are present in humans.
And this is known as
the Human Cell Atlas.
And I just want you
to take a minute
to think about if you wanted
to define different cell types,
what would you look at to
classify these cell types?
Anyone have an idea?
Yes?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Rachel.
ADAM MARTIN: Rachel.
AUDIENCE: Cell function.
ADAM MARTIN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Function.
ADAM MARTIN: You could
look at function.
That might be a little
subjective in how to interpret.
What defines the
function of the cell?
AUDIENCE: I'm thinking
like what it does
and how it works
with other cells.
ADAM MARTIN: But
is there something,
I guess, within
that cell that would
define what its function is?
Yeah?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Samantar
ADAM MARTIN: Samantar?
ADAM MARTIN: Samantac
All right, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Gene expression data.
ADAM MARTIN: Gene
expression, right?
What genes are these
cells expressing?
So what they're doing is
they're isolating single cells
from tissues.
And then they're looking
at gene expression.
So which type of
molecule here would
be the molecule you'd want
to look at if you want
to look at gene expression?
Not Miles.
Malik.
AUDIENCE: You look at mRNA.
ADAM MARTIN: mRNA, exactly.
Malik is exactly right.
So you look at the mRNA, right?
Because if there's mRNA, that
means that gene was expressed,
and it's possibly encoding
the translation of a protein.
So that's what they're doing.
They're isolating single cells
and doing a massive single cell
RNA seek project.
And that's helping
to identify new cell
types in the human body.
OK, coming back to compartments.
So I showed you this picture.
You can see there are lots of
membrane-bound compartments
in the cell.
You can see the
lines in this cartoon
represent lipid bilayers.
And so these are
compartments that
are completely encapsulated
by a lipid bilayer.
And I'm going to
remind you of something
that Professor Imperiali
told you about already.
And the reason I'm
saying it again
is because it is so
freaking important, OK?
So if we consider
a lipid bilayer
where the circles are the
polar head groups of the lipids
and the squiggly lines are
the fatty acid chains--
I'm not going to draw all
the fatty acid chains.
So this is a lipid bilayer.
And these head groups, are they
hydrophilic or hydrophobic?
Yes?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Stephen.
ADAM MARTIN: Stephen.
AUDIENCE: They're hydrophilic.
ADAM MARTIN:
They're hydrophilic.
They like water, right?
The water is on the
different faces here.
These are hydrophilic.
How about this
central region here?
Yes?
Name?
AUDIENCE: Ory.
ADAM MARTIN: Ory.
AUDIENCE: Hydrophobic.
ADAM MARTIN:
Hydrophobic, good, right?
That's excellent.
So these are hydrophobic.
Hydrophobic.
So what that means is you have
this hydrophobic layer that is
surrounding each of
these compartments,
and that's going to serve
as a barrier such that water
and things dissolved in water
cannot pass through this
barrier unless
something allows it to.
So each of these compartments
are membrane bound,
have properties in
the lumen that's
in the interior of
the compartment that's
going to be different from
that of the cytoplasm.
And the cell, the
interior of the cytoplasm,
is going to be different from
that of the extracellular
space.
So let me just give
you some examples
of how things are different
inside and outside the cell
and also inside and
outside these compartments.
So if we consider the
plasma versus the cytoplasm,
we can consider the
concentration of various ions.
And I want to get the
concentrations right.
Let's consider sodium, which is
a monovalent cation, potassium,
and calcium.
I'm just going to use
these as illustrations.
So sodium is concentrated
outside the cell,
about 150 millimolar,
and is less concentrated
in the cytoplasm.
So there's a huge difference
in sodium between the outside
and the inside of the cell.
Potassium-- now, you
might think potassium
would be a lot like sodium.
It's a monovalent cation.
It's a similar size.
But it actually shows
the flip distribution.
So it's four millimolar
in the exoplasm
and 140 millimolar
in the cytoplasm, OK?
So there appears to be some
selectivity here, right?
The cell is concentrating
certain things
inside the cytoplasm, and
it's excluding others.
So there's selectivity, even
between closely related atoms
here.
OK, calcium is two millimolar
in the exoplasm and around 10
to the negative fifth
millimolar in the cytoplasm.
So because there are these huge
gradients in the concentration
of these ions leads
you to expect that this
is a non-equilibrium state.
Because if it were equilibrium,
these ions would go in and out,
and they'd equilibrate such that
the same concentration would be
on the inside as the outside.
And so there's selectivity.
And also, there's
non-equilibrium,
which suggests that
energy is required
to maintain this asymmetry.
I want to point out it's
not just the concentrations
of various molecules that are
different between the inside
and the outside, but the
plasma membrane can also
have a voltage across it.
So this is exoplasm.
This is cytoplasm.
And this membrane
can hold a voltage.
And this is going to become
incredibly important when
we talk about neurons,
because neurons use changes
in this voltage to transmit
signals across their length
and also to transmit
signals at the synapse.
And we'll talk about
that later in the course.
So this is known as
membrane potential,
this voltage difference.
I also, again, want to point
out this endomembrane system
in here, where the
gray regions here
are sort of compartments
that will communicate
with each other.
And so there's this
whole internal structure
of endomembrane system
which is compartmentalized
from the cytoplasm, OK?
And so now I want to talk
about how do things get
in and out of this structure.
So I think we're up to
three, getting in and out.
So cells-- and this is
very important in cell
communication, right?
For cells to
communicate, cells have
to send things, like
signals, to other cells.
And also, cells
can take in stuff
and sort of receive
things from other cells.
So how is it that this happens?
Well, if we consider the
plasma membrane of a cell--
this is a lipid bilayer, PM.
I abbreviate Plasma
Membrane, PM.
So that's a lipid bilayer.
And let's say that there's
some type of sort of molecule
that's on the
outside of the cell.
So, in this case, this
would be exoplasm out here.
This would be inside
the cytoplasm here.
Let's say this cell
wanted to sort of take up
this pink structure
into the cell.
How would it do that?
Well, this pink structure,
because it's hydrophilic,
cannot pass through
the lipid bilayer.
So the cell has to
use another strategy
to take this up into the cell.
Let's see.
I'll use a little blue here.
So let's say the region of the
membrane right here is in blue.
Then, what can happen is this
blue structure can invaginate,
and it can take up
this pink molecule.
So the plasma membrane
can invaginate.
The plasma membrane
can invaginate,
and if it has this
pink molecule,
then if there is a
cision event here,
you've now gone from
having your pink molecule
on the outside of
the cell to having
the pink molecule in this
vesicle or circular structure
on the inside of the cell.
So here now we have this.
We have our vesicle in blue.
And now the cell has picked
up this pink molecule,
such like this.
So this process of
sort of taking material
from the outside and
sort of bringing it
into the inside of
the cell is known
as endocytosis, which is the
process of taking something
from the outside and bringing
it in the cell, this is also
a way that viruses
can get in your cells,
which is a more nefarious
way that this system is used.
All right, I need a volunteer.
Yes.
Ory, come on down.
Don't worry.
This'll be simple.
I just need you to put
pressure on my head right here.
So you see the tassel.
Make sure they can
see the tassel.
You see this tassel?
This tassel is
that pink molecule,
is right now on
the outside, right?
But I'm going to endocytose
it by going like that, right?
And I also got a hand.
That's great.
So you see, that's
basically endocytosis.
I just endocytosed my tassel.
All right, you can go up.
We're all set, yeah.
I can do the next one.
OK, so the opposite
of this process--
let me get another color here.
You can also have vesicles that
are on the inside that then
fuse with the plasma membrane
and release their contents
to the exterior.
And this is called exocytosis.
So exocytosis is
something that's
starting out inside one of these
vesicles and then goes out, OK?
So this is not
exactly reversible,
because there are different
protein machineries that
mediate either
endocytosis or exocytosis.
So now I'm going to
exocytose my tassel.
There we go.
So I just exocytosed it, and
now my molecules is again
facing the outside world.
So this is a way for cells
to sort of taken things
and also to secrete molecules,
like signaling molecules,
into the extracellular space.
So now, we're moving
on, and now we're
going to talk about compartments
within compartments.
So we're on four--
compartments within
compartments.
And you're going to see how
this relates to endocytosis
in just a minute.
So compartments
within compartments.
So the example I'm
going to use here
is an organelle that
is present in us,
in animal cells, which
is the mitochondria.
And you all know
that the mitochondria
is the powerhouse of the cell.
Whenever I say mitochondria is
the powerhouse of the cells,
I have to do 10 push-ups,
because it's so cliche.
I mean, my five-year-old
knows that mitochondria
is the powerhouse of the cell.
It's a gross
oversimplification, OK?
Mitochondria are way more
interesting than that,
and I'll show you
in just a minute.
All right, I'll
draw mitochondria,
the same mitochondria
that my kids draw me.
So here's a mitochondria.
I'm drawing first
the outer membrane.
So there's an outer membrane
to the mitochondria.
And this organelle also
has an inner membrane.
So this is the inner membrane.
The inside here is
called the matrix.
I'll draw some DNA
molecules there.
So this is known as the
mitochondrial DNA, which
I'll mention in just a minute.
So this is the mitochondria.
Where could such an organelle
come from, evolutionarily
speaking?
You know, one problem that
eukaryotic cells have is they
cannot make
mitochondria de novo.
The way that
mitochondria is passed on
is it's replicated
during cell division,
and it's passed on from
one cell to the next.
And you guys all got
your mitochondrial DNA
and your mitochondria, at least
initially, from your mother.
So this is not an organelle
that can be synthesized de novo.
And the fact that
this is the case
has led to a theory known
as the endosymbiont theory,
or hypothesis, which basically
states that there was
an ancestral eukaryotic cell.
And the way that organelles such
as mitochondria and plastids
were derived is from
engulfing bacterial cells that
were either capable of
oxidative phosphorylation,
in the case of mitochondria, or
were capable of photosynthesis,
in the case of chloroplasts.
And so this engulfment is much
like this endocytic process
that I just talked to you.
It's not really endocytosis,
because these bacteria
are much better than
an endocytic vesicle.
So it's more of like a
macro sort of pinocytosis
or something like that, OK?
So something you may have
seen in the news lately--
so some of the evidence for
this endosymbiont theory
is that mitochondria and
plastids have their own DNA,
OK?
So these organelles
have retained DNA.
The genes in the DNA
encode for proteins, that
function in the mitochondria.
It also includes ribosomal
RNAs and transfer RNAs
that are required
for protein synthesis
within the mitochondria.
But a lot of the genes that
are required for a functioning
organism have now been
exported to our nuclear DNA,
and those genes are made
and proteins are produced,
and then they're imported
into the mitochondria.
But the mitochondria has
retained a number of genes,
and it's encoded in
the mitochondrial DNA.
Another reason to
think that this
could be from a symbiotic
relationship, this ancient,
between eukaryotic
and prokaryotic cells
is that these organelles
divide by fission
similar to how bacteria divide.
So they divide by fission.
So I'll show you a
real mitochondria
and a mitochondria undergoing
fission in just a minute.
I just want to point out
that in the news recently,
there's been talk of
three-parent babies.
And I just want to explain
to you what that is.
So eggs that are--
I shouldn't say
embryos, but eggs
that have the nuclear
DNA from two parents
can then be given mitochondrial
DNA from another parent.
So these three-parent
babies are essentially
babies that have
nuclear DNA from two
parents but mitochondrial
DNA from a third parent.
So here's just an article in
the NewScientist reporting
that this is imminent,
and now it's been done.
Now, why would you
might want to do that?
Anyone know why someone
would want to do this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There might be a
defect in the mitochondrial DNA
of both parents.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah.
So Stephen, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ADAM MARTIN: Stephen's
exactly right, right?
There are diseases
that are so associated
with faulty mitochondrial DNA.
And if you're a mother and
you have the mutations that
cause this disease, this
would be a way for you
to have a child without passing
on the disease to your child.
And so this is something
that is still controversial,
but that's why people are
exploring the opportunity
for making these so-called
three-parent babies.
Again, I've a pet peeve
with textbook pictures
of mitochondria.
Here's your textbook picture.
Everything's labeled nicely.
This is what mitochondria
look like in real life.
Mitochondria, like the
endoplasmic reticulum,
actually, form these tubular
networks that essentially
span the entire cell.
So it's convenient for
us to depict mitochondria
like this in textbook,
but mitochondria are
way more interesting than that.
They're dynamic organelles.
And I also want to make
the point-- we kind of talk
about these organelles
like they behave
as these separate
entities, but in fact, they
interact with each other.
And there's lots of interesting
biology behind that.
So I'm going to show
you one movie that's
from work done by Gia Voeltz,
and this Friedman person
is the first author.
She just gave a talk
here at MIT and showed
some beautiful movies.
All right, focus
on this movie here.
The ER is labeled in green,
and the mitochondria is in red.
And what you see is there
is this mitochondria tubule,
and it's crossed by
the ER right here.
Now, focus on this
when the movie plays.
You're going to see that the
mitochondria undergoes fission
right at these points, where
the ER and the mitochondria
intersect.
So that illustrates-- and
now they've mechanistically
dissected what sort of makes
the mitochondria undergo fission
at these crossing sites.
But it really
illustrates the real sort
of complexity and
dynamics that are
present in a cell,
which you might not
be getting from your book.
Oh, I did want to mention that--
so there's a chapter
in your book--
I think it's Key Concept 5.3--
where you can read about
all the organelles.
You should read that and know
roughly what the organelles do.
I mean, I could
lecture about that,
but it would just be so
boring that I can't do it.
I'd have to do a
ton of push-ups.
So we have to sort of choose
what we lecture about.
So I would just suggest you
read that part in the textbook.
If you have questions,
come talk to me.
And just be familiar with what
your organelles are doing.
Yes, Ory?
AUDIENCE: What was the chapter?
ADAM MARTIN: It's 5.3.
AUDIENCE: Is it like a chapter?
ADAM MARTIN: It's
Key Concept 5.3.
It's probably listed in
the assignments, right?
AUDIENCE: It's a
section in the chapter.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's
only a little bit.
It's not going to be long.
ADAM MARTIN: All right.
I have one last part,
which is to prepare you
for Friday's lecture.
In Friday's lecture,
we're going to start
talking about genetics.
And before we talk
about genetics,
we're going to talk
about something that is--
we're going to lay the
groundwork, essentially,
for genetics by talking
about how cells divide.
So I think one of the
most miraculous things
that cells do is that they
can undergo this trick where
they replicate themselves and
split it into two daughter
cells.
And you're seeing here, there
are chromosomes in the middle
here.
They're going to line up
along the metaphase plate.
And now they're going to get
pulled to separate sides.
They're going to wiggle
back and forth first.
Then, in just a minute, they're
going to get segregated.
They'll go eventually.
There they go.
So you see-- and
then the cell is
going to pinch at the equator
and divide in two, OK?
So now I'm at this last
part, the cytoskeleton,
because the cytoskeleton
is the answer to part
of how these cells divide.
And before I present
the cytoskeleton,
I just want to briefly
mention chromosomes
and what they look like.
So the chromosomes
are your nuclear DNA.
They're linear pieces of DNA,
as opposed to the mitochondria,
which has circular DNA.
And again, the fact that
mitochondria have circular DNA
is analogous with sort of
bacterial chromosomes, where
bacteria have circular DNA.
But our chromosomes are
linear pieces of DNA.
And you guys have probably
all seen chromosome spreads
that look like this.
So this would be a
chromosome that's replicated.
There are two
copies, one and two.
So this is a replicated and
condensed chromosome, right?
Initially, chromosomes are
just like bowls of spaghetti.
Everything's mixed together.
But during mitosis, the
chromosomes condense, and then
they sort of resolve
from each other, such
that you can see the
arms of the chromosome.
And you can see where the
chromosomes are coupled
to each other at
this structure here,
which is known as
the centromere.
And at this centromere, a
protein complex assembles.
I'll just draw it like this.
This protein complex is
called the kinetochore.
The kinetochore is a
complex of hundreds
of proteins that assemble
into this large platform that
sits on the centromere.
And the kinetochore
is able to attach
to the cell's cytoskeleton,
specifically microtubules.
So this attaches
to microtubules.
And I will tell you what
microtubules are right now.
So microtubules are a component
of the cell's cytoskeleton.
So the cell's cytoskeleton is
a network of filamentous rods
that are present in the cell.
And the term
cytoskeleton kind of
makes it sound boring,
I think, because it
makes it sound static.
But the cytoskeleton
is anything but static.
It's actually a dynamic
machine in the cell.
And these machines that are
assembled from these fibers
are able to generate force.
So these microtubules
and the cytoskeleton,
they generate force.
You can think of them
as motors or machines.
So there are machines
that generate force.
And I'll just illustrate
this with a couple of videos
and slides.
So, again, this is not a stable
structure, but very dynamic.
So this is going to be a
movie where, in green here,
microtubules are labeled, and
the red label's the nucleus.
And these cells
in this fly embryo
are going to undergo
cycles of nuclear division.
And so you're going to see
the microtubules assemble,
disassemble,
assemble, disassemble.
So you see how dynamic
this process is.
The cell is able to assemble
this force-generating
apparatus, which is known
as the mitotic spindle, each
and every cell division.
So this structure,
or machine, is
critical to physically
segregate the chromosomes
to opposite poles of a cell.
So now I'm going to tell
you about the microtubules
themselves.
So microtubules, as
the name implies,
are sort of tube-like polymers.
So these microtubules
are biopolymers,
which means that cells are
expressing sort of genes that
encode for proteins that
form a subunit that can then
self-assemble into a
larger rod-like structure.
And you can see one of these
rod-like structures here.
They essentially
look like straws.
They're about 25
nanometers in diameter.
And I'm going to show
you this video showing
you microtubules both
disassembling at first
and then assembling.
So that's a dissembling
microtubule.
But they also assemble
to form these longer
rod-like structures.
So these biopolymers
are dynamic,
and they both assemble
but also disassemble.
And both the assembly and the
disassembly can generate force.
Microtubules can push if they
polymerize into something.
They push it, right?
Just like you're kind of poking
someone with your finger.
Now, they also
disassemble, and when
they shrink and disassemble,
they can actually pull.
And I'll show you an
example of that right here.
So this is an example that's
reconstituted, meaning they're
just purified proteins here.
There's no cell.
And what this is, is a bead.
And you see the dark stripe
here is a microtubule.
You can see it growing.
There's the end right there.
That microtubule's
going to grow.
It's going to grow
out to about here.
And then at the
end of the movie,
it's going to stop growing,
and the microtubule's
going to shrink back.
And you're going to see that
when the microtubule shrinks
back, it's going to actually
pull this large bead
and pull it towards the
left side of the slide.
Here it goes.
It depolymerizes and pulls.
You see it?
So these microtubules
can generate
a pulling force that's strong
enough to pull this glass bead.
And also, it's strong enough
to pull an entire chromosome.
It's actually much stronger--
it generates much
more force than it
requires to pull a chromosome.
So it seems like there's
some robustness in the system
so that it's generating
a pull that's
much stronger than needed to
actually drag a chromosome
through viscus media.
So during mitosis, the
way this system is set up
is there's what's known
as a bipolar spindle.
I'll just write down that.
We'll come back to it
in Friday's lecture.
There's a bipolar spindle.
And the bipolar spindle is made
up of a number of microtubules.
So here, you can see there
are two poles, here and here.
And in the middle, along the
sort of equator of the cell,
the chromosomes will line up.
There are just two
chromosomes here.
And you can see how microtubules
reach out from the pole
and attach to both sides
of that chromosome.
And you can imagine that
when these microtubules are
told to shrink and
disassemble, if they're
able to remain attached to that
kinetochore, which they are,
when they shrink,
they're going to pull
the two copies of the chromosome
away from each other, OK?
And so this is the
basic machinery
that allows for chromosomes
to be segregated in cells.
OK, that's it for today.
Any questions?
All right, terrific.
Good luck on your
exam on Wednesday.
It's in here.